salieron el miércoles y el jueves desde
san pedro sula honduras llevando solo lo
que tienen puesto y algunos con algo más
de ropa se fueron con la firme idea de
caminar más de tres mil kilómetros para
huir de la pobreza no importa el frío o
la falta de comida podrían ser hasta
nueve mil hombres mujeres ancianos y
niños todos hondureños y dispuestos a
enfrentarse a las dificultades para
escapar de la miseria la violencia y la
falta de oportunidades
mujer y mis hijos
quiero darle un futuro a ellos quiero
que ellos
pues no viva en lo que yo he vivido
qué es algo bien difícil aquí
en honduras
el país no es malo las autoridades son
las malas
impulsados por la profundización de la
pobreza en el último año a causa de la
pandemia y el paso de dos huracanes los
migrantes hondureños esperan lograr su
objetivo de llegar a eeuu según la
comisión económica para américa latina
en honduras más del 57% de la población
vive bajo el nivel de pobreza y uno de
cada cinco hondureños en una situación
de pobreza extrema
no hay igualmente vamos a un sueño
americano porque en el país no hay
trabajo no hay empleo mucha delincuencia
y la verdad que a quien no se puede
vivir verdad nosotros vivíamos en una
casa igual como el huracán de yota se
llevó el nuestra casita y
en su camino se han enfrentado y se
seguirán enfrentando a retenes tanto en
guatemala como en mexico por motivos de
seguridad o de salud pública pero todos
tienen la esperanza en que el presidente
electo joe biden que prestará juramento
el miércoles a libia la política
migratoria de eeuu como lo prometió
durante su campaña